elles sont visibles de partout à rouyn
noranda les deux immenses cheminées de
la fonderie horne
cette fonderie qui domine la ville
depuis près d'un siècle suscite
aujourd'hui des craintes à cause de ses
émissions toxiques
pourquoi est ce qu'ils disent qu'il faut
donc qu'ils sont deux là n'en présente
pas nos enfants
le taux d'arsenic dans l'air préoccupent
les citoyens les parents comme irait
vincelette dans l'étude de l'automne
dernier ma fille avait exposé 12 fois
plus aller retour dans ce n'est que tu
sois plus important dans ses ongles que
le groupe témoin d'amos pour monfils
c'est quatre fois plus
la direction de la santé publique s'est
penché sur la question dans un rapport
publié le mois passé
elle constate que les enfants qui vivent
près de la fonderie sont de trois à
quatre fois plus imprégné que la normale
à l'arsenic une substance cancérigène
on nous a été recommandé pour diminuer
l'exposition des affaires de mettre un
couvert toujours sur notre carré de
sable de fermer les fenêtres qui a
éventé de pub passer l'aspirateur en
présence de vente parce que le taux
d'arsenic
oui c'était fait parce que l'arsenic de
poussière d'arsenic dans l'air qui peut
rentrer dans la maison puis être mis en
suspension selon la santé publique
l'arsenic augmente les risques de cancer
chez les enfants de moins de 6 ans les
pactes peut être majeurs ce à long terme
céder plus de chances de développer un
cancer puis à plus court terme en fait
c'est plus de chances de développer des
effets neurodéveloppementaux comme une
page du puits un bébé qui échappent ça
sur sa terre dans la table cela mène à
un beau jeu mais il peut avoir pris une
bonne dose d'arsenic
il faut qu'il y ait des actions qui
soient menées immédiatement pour réduire
l'exposition des
on peut d'ailleurs lire dans le rapport
que des actions concrètes doivent être
mises en place immédiatement par les
acteurs clés afin que la population ne
soient plus exposées de façon chronique
à des émissions atmosphériques d'arsenic
la fonderie horne à presque 100 ans
c'est un des poumons économiques de
rouyn noranda les dirigeants de lusine
sont bien conscients des inquiétudes
reliées à l'arsenic
moi je dors dans le quartier l'enfant
mais plusieurs membres de la direction
et des cadres qui demeure dans le
quartier ici les préoccupent et de fait
de voir finalement toute l'anxiété qui
est générée par ce dossier là le rapport
conclut équidés pas capables de conclure
à des effets à la santé cependant on
peut appliquer le principe de précaution
lusine propriété de la multinationale
glencore emploie des centaines de
travailleurs
ils ont tous des bons salaires il gagne
2,70 à 100 mille dollars par année dans
des 6 160 employés actuellement plus
environ 140 d'entrepreneurs qui sont là
en tout 1 800 emplois c'est très très
significatif je pense pour la région au
niveau de la masse salariale les
employés ici de l'apport que sa loi dans
la communauté on parle d'environ 80
millions juste les employés de la
fonderie on peut rajouter un quart en
une quarantaine de millions pour les
entrepreneurs qui travaillent ici la
fonderie horne est omniprésente à rouyn
noranda
chaque année elle injecte de près d'un
demi million $ en dons ou encore en
commandite
peu de gens donc ici aux critiques et
l'entreprise et encore moins parler du
dossier de l'arsenic et les gens des
conseils que la fonderie aujourd'hui est
un acteur important du développement
économique
les jeunes seront pas intéressés à se
mettre
tu parlais contre une entreprise qui
contribue à créer rouyn noranda
le dossier est émotif il déchire la
population c'est un sujet délicat est
important mais il faut que les gens
osent en parler moi je me positionne
comme entre les deux je compte de la
fonderie je suis pas un défenseur et les
fonderies donc c'est certain que c'est
un joueur important mais en même temps
je pense que la santé devrait toujours
et à l'avant scène
le dossier est encore plus délicat pour
les travailleurs de la fonderie de tout
et très la fonderie sont très sensibles
à situations sont sensibles aux chiffres
qui est sortie concernant les enfants
mais on est aussi censé bas nous
travaillons notre travail on veut pas
perdre notre job non plus 75 80 %
maintenant des travailleurs sont des
jeunes jeunes jeunes en bas de 12 ans
d'ancienneté qui sont assurément lié
avec les banques pour des hypothèques
avec des petites familles à nourrir dans
la foulée du rapport de septembre le
ministre de l'environnement donner aux
dirigeants de la fonderie jusqu'au 15
décembre pour présenter un plan d'action
afin de réduire les émissions d'arsenic
pour les résidents c'est insuffisant
l'ultimatum lancé par québec est trop
vague a demandé de faire un plan
d'action concret pas mais il n'y a pas
de cible pas calendrier donc c'est un
peu du foutage de nuages pourquoi vivre
si vous pourriez déménager le problème
irait li na dans la ville un quartier
super dynamique culturelle avec des
gens' paraître à la fin j'ai vécu toute
ma vie donc le ministre de
l'environnement se fait rassurant ce
plan d'action la d'oeuvre non seulement
comporter des mesures à court terme mais
plan d'action à plus long terme qui lui
devra viser la teinte des normes
canadiennes en termes d'émissions
d'arsenic
de son côté la fonderie promet
d'investir de réduire les émissions
d'arsenic comme elle l'a déjà fait dans
le passé avec le plomb par exemple un
projet actuellement qui est en cours où
on estime qu'on va les chercher une
réduction d'environ 10 à prendre pour
cent très significatif mais l'on
traverse a dit à des ténors que sont
encore
loin de la norme provinciale pour
atteindre par exemple les cibles qui
sont fixés par le gouvernement du québec
vous estimez que pour votre fonderie
votre entreprise ça pourrait prendre
combien de temps j'estime que c'était
impossible pour nous d'atteindre la
cible du règlement sur les ismes
l'assainissement de l'atmosphère qui du
coup on en aura donc actuellement notre
cible actuelle les 200 nano grammes on
obtient des résultats autour de 120
degrés le gouvernement du québec permet
actuellement la fonderie de rejeter dans
l'ère des taux d'arsenic jusqu'à 67 fois
plus élevé que la norme québécoise ce
genre d'entente l'eau entre le
gouvernement et l'entreprise en a plus
de 80 au québec c'est pas seulement
autour de la fonderie les seuls sont
tellement contaminées dans le quartier
que la fonderie doit décontaminer chaque
année plusieurs terrains on enlève les
sols on en met dix nouveaux et on refait
le terrassement pour la mairesse ou si
la situation est complexe
la priorité c'est la santé du citoyen et
en même temps un employeur on se
retrouve à la fermeture de l'entreprise
alors il faut vraiment travailler à des
solutions
la ville étudie la possibilité de verdir
le quartier d'asphalté les ruelles et de
créer une zone tampon entre la fonderie
et les résidences comme le recommande la
direction de la santé publique
ce choix de société qui ne va devoir se
faire est ce que on met la santé à la 20
en tant que société québécois au jour où
on fait dominer l'économie je sais pas
les résidents du quartier eux ont bien
l'intention de poursuivre leur combat
on veut demander au gouvernement de
faire pression nous on n'a pas de
pouvoir de faire changer de l'encore par
canton reste à convaincre le
gouvernement de de leur serrer un peu la
viste
ses soeurs casal femmes des choses d'ici
là les résidents du quartier attendent
avec impatience le plan d'action que
doit déposer la fonderie
[Musique]